terry bradshaw joining us the hall of
famer Fox NFL Sunday analyst four times
Super Bowl win
Terry good morning how are you I heard
you talking about Copper River salmon
good stuff it's unbelievable I had it
and it's only available a short time of
the year two weeks I believe two weeks
and the reasons are so good is they have
to get so fat just go up that extremely
cold river coldest River there is and
that's why they taste so good but you're
right two weeks two years all you can
get them I've had one Copper River
salmon I'm like oh my god this is
amazing
well that's all I wanted to talk to you
about Terry thanks for joining us last
time you threw a football yeah yeah
lifetime last Sunday oh okay yeah I'm
the studio I throw I throw it every
Sunday okay can't help myself pick it up
and throw it if we were just if I got
you loose how far could you throw it
right now I mean I could throw it one
time forty yards one time I got a
ligament my ligaments torn but I could
throw it one time for you
forty yards I mean you know why hey Dad
I mean I'd be able to go farther but I
know forty I can make forty yards one
time yeah at your peak went in your
prime is you I you had one of the great
arms of all time and and that probably
helped be in a javelin thrower as well
but how far could you throw all right
I'm gonna take exactly out fort because
one day after the practice coach uli
hedges on and coach Williams says they
said huh how far can you throw this
thing and I went I have no idea they
stood me on the goal line and I threw it
84 yards that's a long way I went to a
competition in the NFL and I threw it 70
76 yards and Dan Pastorini I believe
through it 79 yards so I lost I lost
some distance
do you need a big arm to be a
quarterback no no you need a big brain
to see and anticipate and the ball gets
out there you don't I mean if you've got
the if you've got the gun it's actually
if you have it's good to have the gun
but one of the hardest things for a guy
with a strong arm which I had a hard
time doing was to check down so in the
little wide flares and the quick outs
and stuff those are the harder things
guys like Drew Brees that's the perfect
arm from the NFL great mind great
anticipation awesome offense spotted on
accuracy just amazing like Brady Brady
has a really great arm love is delivery
there are several guys in the league
that have really nice honors but you
don't need a cannon no I'm like Alan and
Buffalo you don't need a nice to have it
but you got to learn how to put a
governor on it we were talking earlier
prior to the show and I said to my guys
I said look at Joe Turkey Jones when he
heard Terry
he picked you up and threw you down you
know we're looking at these rules to
protect the quarterback here I mean
going back when you played did you ever
feel like they were trying to protect
the quarterback no no it wasn't no no we
were just grabbing bodyslam him hit him
in the head kick him in the face no it's
it was the way the game I guess it's the
way the game people loved it was a
really tough tough physical game I would
have appreciated don't pile on the
quarterback with all your weight like
that one that's one of the funniest
rules I swear I've ever heard but I
could I could I would have enjoyed
knowing that that you can't hit me below
the waist that would have been great I
mean it has it has definitely the rules
definitely have tilted toward offense
and definitely toward the quarterback
which is you know for a guy like me you
know you your pride stops gets out in
front of your Dan you go
yeah he was the best ever let's see him
play in the 70s when you can bodyslam
them and hit them and so and so forth
but then if you say that you're jealous
you know then I could say well if I had
25 million bucks I wouldn't mind getting
hit like that but then you're jealous
because you only made 300 thousand so
you're better off keeping your mouth
shut which I'm not going to do he's
absolutely
he's the Hall of Famer Terry Bradshaw
joining us Dan Patrick show does it
bother you when your name doesn't come
up automatically when we talk about
great quarterbacks because you got four
Super Bowl rings and and so does Joe
Montana but you know it's like Joe
Montana is the best quarterback of all
time it felt like and then all of a
sudden Tom Brady comes along and you
want four Super Bowls and played for
probably the best defense in NFL history
so I don't know why well I wasn't
featured it wasn't quarterback wasn't a
feature of the greatness of the Steelers
it was the running game and the awesome
defense I was just you know out there
calling plays and and running the
football it wasn't our offense was not
designed for passing like it like the
game is now I just did my job that was
the way I was coached and that's what
they wanted and I did what we wanted and
we won four Super Bowls and I went off
into the sunset it's not that important
to me to be you calls me a legend or you
call me an icon or you call me a
superstar a hall-of-famer it those
things are not that important to me do I
get upset Howie long came to me dad one
time and he says you saw this deal out
the top quarterbacks in the league and
you weren't even missing in the top
tails around with these guys and I
thought now that you know what they
danced that says it all when when you're
come comrades are sticking up for you
then that says it all and I and I enjoy
that but it doesn't faze me it doesn't
faze me at all if you could talk to lay
me on Bell what would you tell him well
I would tell him get your butt in get
your butt in and I would tell the
Steelers sign this guy you sure
find him already it's a game of offense
it's all about offense my god they
scored 42 points in the playoff game and
they fired the offensive coordinator
having yet to figure that out so I would
get in go play he needs to be in
Pittsburgh Pittsburgh needs him if they
win a Super Bowl it's gonna be because
of levy on bail okay they need him to
play and he needs to sign and now
they're butting heads and now the
offensive linemen are talking against
him so now he's probably gonna pack his
bags and head somewhere else do you put
I guess there's blame to go around on
both sides here but if the Steelers had
paid him it's hard with running backs
Terry because actually right right I
mean I don't think the salaries are
equal to what they're asked to do in lay
beyond Bell is probably the best
all-around back in football Gurley
Le'Veon Bell maybe Elliot and Dallas but
not really when these two I just popped
they're the best levy on bill is amazing
athlete and you're right but he is more
than just a running back he's a receiver
out of the backfield he's electrifying
he's fast he's got great hands great
vision here's a rare back and we just
don't see that but you're right running
backs are not considered that importer
as and these guys are and they should be
considered key to our success you work
with Burt Reynolds did you work on on
Hooper was that the only time you worked
with with birtherism ball Ron I did
Cannonball Run Hooper smoking bandit two
and three evening shades with him Wow oh
wow yeah we kind of went down to his
dinner theater we used to go out to
dinner all the time go over to Dinah
Shores house with him he's a wonderful
man what kind of football player was he
I don't know I think he was a star in
high school pretty good in college till
he got hurt I'm not real sure do you
think he wanted to be you you guys both
did pretty well in the field but it does
work
you'll get the position or the actor who
wants to be the athlete and then the
other way around
cross it over exactly tell us what
you're doing with all about your boom
campaign all about your boom is the deal
Pfizer called me and asked me would I be
a part of the baby boomer campaign they
have which is 65 and older and it's a
campaign that is designed to bring
awareness the pneumococcal pneumonia and
all about your boomers there seem you
can go to all about your boom calm it's
the commercial I shot and it explains
everything in a comical way and then it
hits the home it hits the magic point at
the end and it's a it's a great campaign
you're nowhere near a baby boomer Dan
Patrick so you don't have to worry about
pneumococcal pneumonia actually this is
going to shock you I can spell it - all
right Wow yeah Wow wait do you have it
right in front of you Terry yeah well I
figured that I got a couple more years
and then I'll get there I was also why
yeah did you keep any memorabilia like
the Immaculate reception I gave you
nothing no I have no you come in my
house you'll see no football nothing and
I gave all the good stuff away to the
Louisiana Tech University and all my
pictures are of my family my dad my
horses chickens Bulls they're telling me
I got a hang up okay hey hey let's
continue this some other time because we
got a lot of things we got to talk about
Terry I'd love to thanks for joining us
good to have you back it's a Terry
Bradshaw all of Fame Fox NFL Sunday
analysts four-time Super Bowl champ he
got some energy there bring some bring
some levity that's for sure but also you
know sometimes when somebody has an
approach like that you don't take you're
not really listening to what they're
telling you because he'll say it in a
joking manner or lively but he's also
telling you something as well you know
and that that's why I always appreciate
it because if you do listen to Terry
when he's doing the Fox NFL Sunday he
can come off as kind of loose kind of
goofy at times but then there are times
when you know he's he's really telling
you something it gets disguised
sometimes by how he's telling you
something for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]